Here's an interesting question that came in
via voicemail.
Yesterday, I interviewed Jesse Lee Peterson
on the program and a lot of people had some
version of this question.
Take a listen to it.
Hey, David.
Joel in Florida, I watched your interview
with Jesse Lee Peterson.
Right.
He clips where he interviewed you in the past.
Like some of the clips of his show.
I've looked online.
My question is, is this guy for real?
Is this sort of like a Phil Hendrie where
he's playing a character or right buddy routine?
Or is this for real?
I was just wondering what you think about
that.
Yeah.
So a lot of people have asked me this.
I do not believe Jesse Lee Peterson is playing
a character.
And the reason I don't believe that is when
I went to his studio in Los Angeles, he was
exactly the same affair.
Now, maybe he's playing and I'm talking like
he's talking about Trump stuff and saying
all the same things.
Maybe it's such a commitment to the character
that he even continues off air.
But I don't think Jesse Lee Peterson is playing
a character which makes it all the more scary.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
One in five recent Corona virus cases are
people in their 20s, people in their 20s.
We will talk about the new Republican focus
on Joe Biden's son, Hunter.
And we will also talk about what Michael Bloomberg
did to enable 32000 additional Floridians
to vote in November.
Very interesting and important stories on
the bonus show get instant access instant
by becoming a member at join Pacman dot com.